I'm John Phillips with wires gadget lab
and I have here an iPad in a case now a
lot of people don't know that the iPad
3G has a proximity sensor and when that
sensor is close enough to your body it
powers down 3G signal strength now this
iPad is in a case from pong research and
the secret sauce in this case is that it
doesn't trip the proximity sensor so I'm
about to enter an over-the-air test
chamber to find out exactly what the
effects of the pong case are on the
iPads proximity sensor inside the OTA
room it's a pretty amazing environment
as you can see the walls are covered
with these absorbing pyramid shapes and
it reduces radio wave reflections and
there are two main apparatus in here we
have the cylinder in the middle that
rotates 360 degrees you put your device
on top of that then against the wall
there's a huge wheel and it rotates 3G
antenna across 165 degree arc and across
these two axes we can build a 3d
representation of the 3G power of any
particular device OTA testing is
complete and we have some very vivid
results so check out the screens behind
me the upper left is the iPad naked no
case whatsoever the upper right is the
iPad with pong Research's case the
bottom is the iPad with a third-party
case and what we found is that total DB
reduction was 6 dB
so that's a pretty significant drop
because of the scale in this context
that represents a 75 percent drop in 3G
power and so how would this affect you
in the real world where if you if you
were on like an outlier far away from a
tower a cell tower you might find that
you couldn't connect to 3G via that
third-party case and this was all
because the case actually trips up the
proximity sensor on the tablet whereas
the pawn case doesn't trip up that
sensor ok so what we have here is
it's mostly water a little bit of
ethanol and it most closely represents
the dielectric properties of human flesh
and it's gonna tell us how much energy
your flesh would absorb were you holding
the iPad to 3G we finished testing and
the results are in and it's pretty vivid
the top screenshot shows the iPad alone
the bottom screenshot shows the iPad
with the palm research case on top and
as you can see the results are pretty
dramatic all total if you want to look
at the numbers the upon case was able to
reduce the radiative energy of the iPad
by 66%